espn nfl insider jeff darlington joins
us right now
to talk a little bit about all things
nfl but first jeff welcome to the show
and
i wanted to ask you the mounting
accusations that that continue to come
out yeah
i mean everybody who covers the nfl like
this has to be in complete
shock that something like this has
landed at the feet
of deshaun watson right now well
absolutely i mean i think the word that
you just used
uh is probably the twist the twist that
this this has sort of created
uh for what is already the biggest
storyline of the offseason
is just so unfortunate and the thing
when i say unfortunate
it's unfortunate either way like
it is unfortunate if this is these are
fabricated allegations
this is unfortunate obviously if they
are not fabricated
i mean this impacts
desean watson's future an organization's
future
and let us not forget of course
um those who are alleging uh
these crimes so i guess
the way i look at this is yes obviously
we are shocked that deshaun watson's
name
is being mentioned with allegations like
these
but um but at the same time we can't let
that
sort of i guess completely change the
way that we look at this the way that we
i guess maintain patience on both sides
and and sort of see how this thing plays
out
jeff darlington uh espn nfl reporter
here
talking about the desean watson
situation the
now i'm not a conspiracy theory uh
theorist
but a few weeks ago i was just like you
know is there a hand in here from the
texans
in terms of when it was a story that
came out on
instagram and everything like that but
the mounting allegations seem to be
like it's a predatory process
and the canceled culture that we're
living in right now makes me want to
think that
hey no one's going to trade for this guy
and why would you with these kind of
things going on
and whether or not desean watson
actually ever plays another down in the
nfl because of it i understand we got to
let
things play out in the courts but i mean
where we sit now
in our culture in our country
there's a good chance that we don't see
desean watson playing football
ever or for a long extended period of
time
well and that's where i think so so two
things first of all i i mean look i i've
got
fram you know we can't be naive to this
like i got friends who ask me all the
time about
stuff that you know entails my work life
where they're like hey do you think the
texans you think this is right
to your point like do you think the
texans did this like i can't wrap my
head around
like i always look for motivation and
incentive um
i mean i i guess we could we can spit
ball on it but like i just don't
understand why
a team that ultimately has to at least
be recognizing that
uh a trade is the most likely resolution
is is they just kill every bit of
leverage that they would have had
now this isn't resolved fully a week
before the nfl draft which is when i
talked to executives the target date of
when the texans
are anticipated to actually start
fielding calls for a trade
um i mean if this isn't resolved by then
like how do they move forward it just it
it changes the whole complexity of what
was already such
a touchy subject
so so i don't believe that it it it does
benefit them
to have done this uh so i i don't
i don't subscribe to that notion but to
to that to that same point about the
timeline i just laid out
like do i think that we'll see desean
watson
um play football again i have no
idea and the idea that
that we're having that conversation
right now
in march um it's just mind-blowing i
just it just literally twists my head up
to where i don't
i don't know what happens next i don't
know what happens next
jeff darlington joining us espn nfl
reporter
that's kind of the question i wanted to
ask like what's next
i feel you man do they i mean they they
went and got tyrod taylor
uh from the uh uh los angeles chargers
who was
who was up and for like 12 million 12
and a half million dollars so
it's a significant amount of money in
all
likelihood they expect uh tyrod taylor
to
as of right now when we're going into
into uh mini camps and things like that
he's
he's most likely going to be the guy
until we have some sort of resolution
um in the desean watson scenario well
and that's that's the thing the fluidity
of this situation first of all i kind of
view the tie rod thing
i understand that that feels like a a
lofty price
um for a backup it it i kind of view it
the way i viewed andy dalton going to
the cowboys last year which was not that
he was going
as a leveraged play for jerry jones in
those negotiations but rather
a really solid backup who is
uh perhaps unexpectedly available on a
one-year deal
where it does provide you security but
even if
it's not an insurance policy it's also a
good backup if things work out so
that being said um i still
i i still look at the the timeline here
i mean it could all like i look at the
uh the comments
yesterday for the statement that that
deshaun watson's uh attorney put out
yesterday and i look at that
and and he says that he's got proof that
one of these allegations
is is a lie right so my thing is
you've got the attorney of the those
alleging the crime and you have the
attorney of deshaun watson both saying
they've got this evidence well
i feel like on either side this thing
could either fall apart
or or get even um even stronger legs
based on what that evidence evidence is
i mean if we see this evidence all of a
sudden it's like
you know the news cycle could literally
just change to where wow deshaun watson
literally was
was part of one of the one of the most
horrible
um you know just
ray donovan cover-ups yeah yeah
character assassinations we've ever seen
that being said like there's a lot of
allegations right now again too many so
it's it's just oh man like
i just i don't know how we got here but
i i will say like i think it was like a
week ago i'm starting to look at this
thing
and you can feel that snowball effect
start to happen like right out of the
gates everybody was like oh deshaun
watson there's no way
and and i'm not saying well i'm um
concluding anything but i was starting
to look at it like man this is not going
to go away
anytime soon like this is go this is
here to stay for the off season
and uh and again it comes back the same
thing i said ryan i don't know where it
ends i have no idea what happens next
and at no point do we want to uh
conclude that that these allegations
aren't
absolutely um
problematic and important either way
yeah either way
that's that's right that's an important
thing ryan
this is horrible either way whatever the
outcome of this
it is it is horrible it is a horrible
outcome
whichever way this thing goes well you
know when the off season started i
wanted to
uh you know dive into the wilson watson
watch
every single day until this thing's
resolved you know so
how is the dissipation of the wilson
side of this russell wilson
uh he's making some announcements now
says he wants uh antonio brown
in in seattle sometime soon uh
does this mean that the idea of russell
wilson being somewhere else next year
is not something that fans should be
looking at anymore
so anything it points me more toward
the idea that he will not be on the
officer in 2021 i i just i don't
it this doesn't feel like it it feels
too public at this point
um when we we went years
in the tom brady bill belichick
relationship
like every time any suggestion of
tension came out we all blasted it
or many blasted it and suggested no way
they're fine
um and it wasn't always fine they got
through it
but when it starts to go public you
realize wow the depth of this
is much it's you know think about like
jared goff and sean mcsay
like a year ago at this time were we
really thinking like that that was
ending in in such a
fast-paced divorce um so when i
translate all that to russell wilson
like i don't know man i just it still
doesn't feel
like we're headed toward russell wilson
in week one in seattle and and
that's that's just kind of based on yes
what i know in terms of
where that relationship is at it doesn't
feel like there's some kubaya thing
going on where they figured it out
um but that is also just a little
instinctive sort of
perspective on on what we've already
experienced with other quarterbacks out
there
wow uh jeff darlington espn nfl reporter
kind of
you kind of took me back there a little
bit because i really thought it was
trending in that other direction that
i mean there's an incredible cap hit
that seattle would take
getting rid of them but they're willing
to take that on to rebuild i don't
look i mean they got it got it it got
close with the bears well i think we all
recognize like
that got closer than yeah and i i refuse
to believe that
that pete carroll just sort of backed
off and said you know what russ is my
guy like when have we heard anything
about rus
russell wilson and pete carroll
basically you know coming out and saying
man
we're in this together where this is you
know our fight to fight it hasn't been
like that so
again like i'm not trying to like stir
it up or anything i'm just
inclined to sort of continue to follow
these tea leaves that are out there
which is
not suggesting that um i mean if
look what happens if antonio brown
doesn't wind up in seattle like i i just
i think there's so much to play out
between now and
the draft let alone the start of the
season that
i don't feel like the russell wilson
situation
has reached any sense of conclusiveness
all right let's get you out of here with
a couple uh um bookkeeping stuff with
the nfl
jeff darlington espn nfl reporter here
on the rich eisen show i'm ryan leaf
filling in for rich um the nfl draft
okay when this came out
and we were told they were going to do
it in cleveland
with some sort of fan interaction what
what was your thought process on us now
i've i've been an outspoken person
around
whether or not you know sports should
have been played in a worldwide pandemic
but
i don't i don't necessarily know if this
is the best
uh thing to do while we're kind of
coming to the end of this
also after what went down last year and
what we saw
in terms of a bunch of those uh high
drafted players at home with their
families
i think we might see more of that in the
years to come
yeah i don't disagree i mean i think
that that was definitely i can't decide
if that was a
like i think we all really enjoyed it
that peek into sort of into those
worlds like espn for instance has always
had like living room cams
last year it was just it felt much more
intimate because it was it was so
it was literally every pick especially
the high ones um
and seeing the gm's in their houses and
cook kingsborough i mean there were so
many great moments
i don't know if that was sort of a flash
in the pan like it was kind of a fun
trend and now let's get back to normal
i don't know but by the way to your
point one of the things i think the nfl
has done well
um and wherever you stand on it in terms
of whether
sports should you know like what what
has happened so far i thought that they
always at least
created a plan they had a plan in place
so that if they got to that point like
the worst thing in the world is to not
have a plan then get there and be like
wow
there's a really good portion of our
population that's vaccinated
we could have these vaccinated people be
at the draft and feel pretty safe about
it um
no i'm not trying to sit here and say
that'll be the case but if if that turns
out to be the case
at least you have put the wheels in
motion to where
you can pull it off yeah um you know so
i i just
i don't know i i commend the nfl on
on continuing to operate as if things
will happen and then as
needed scale back to maintain public
safety and i think
look i mean was this season not a
success
i think it was pretty unbelievable it is
jeff darlington everybody from
espn nfl reporter jeff thanks for taking
the time with me today
i appreciate it man good talking dude
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here